[Música]
apichatpong apio joe son todas las
firmas que hay sobre estos fotogramas su
autor originario de tailandia es uno de
los directores y guionistas más
originales del cine contemporáneo
desde 1993 y tras su ópera prima del año
2000 ha desarrollado una mirada sensible
y espiritual sobre las inquietudes
modernas lo que en 2010 le valió la
palma de oro en el festival de cannes y
en 2021 el premio del jurado ex aequo
por memoria su primer rodaje en el
extranjero en colombia y una conjugación
de su arte y arquitectura tilda swinton
navega por un mundo que se comunica con
ella a través de la luz y el sonido
apichatpong weerasethakul faces muchas
gracias por estar aquí en france 24 tu
película es un collage de memorias una
acumulación de recuerdos individuales
colectivos históricos porque este
interés por recordar
the story of us creo que la historia de
nosotros
como contamos la historia por lo general
antes era más un poder
que ver la narrativa
steve hecho pero ahora es más sobre el
individuo sobre la memoria colectiva que
me parece muy preciosa especialmente
viniendo de tailandia para tener nuestra
propia voz voices
de memoria y por eso siento que esta
película memoria no es sobre colombia
es sobre mí lo que mirando a colombia en
un momento determinado en esta época que
no es su línea es un souvenir de mi
viaje aquí en 2017 quiero entrar en ese
y la gran forma de esta memoria es el
sonido como este viaje sonoro conecta
con el camino que emprende jessica
carácter o física
estos caracteres
creo que este personaje tiene que ver
conmigo y también con tilda swinton aui
interpreta sobre cómo interpretamos la
sensación de estar aquí y conocer el
trasfondo del lugar
photoespaña esteban se originó a partir
de mis síntomas
las que duró unos años cuando tuve esta
explosión en mi cabeza explosión
está aquí es un síndrome cierto ese es
un síndrome en sí después descubrí que
se llama síndrome de la cabeza explosiva
guys novarino work que nadie sabe que lo
causa tal vez sea la depresión tal vez
otra cosa para mí es feliz
pero para mí es muy curioso no es
traumático y no persona sino que es algo
personal que me acompaña en el camino a
estar arriba o
woman así que empecé a escribir sobre
esta mujer que atraviesa estos espacios
diferentes
oren aferrándose a este sonido que ya no
saben qué es y al mismo tiempo está
aferrándose a su propio trauma por el
dolor adecentan si es joven haddon drama
con cruyff
y no huele exactamente en realidad no lo
acepta intenta ir en contra de este
hasta que en un momento de la película
tiene que aceptarlo
junto yo lo que uno se mira a un país
ajeno que recurre al olvido para no
mirar a su propia violencia sus heridas
tailandia
como se mira un país así las artes
compiten fugaz tenemos que competir para
ver cuál es el país más olvidadizo
porque lo olvido es un concepto que
vemos en memoria no ya que santander y a
veces un olvido deliberado
son norfolk eren es importante no
olvidar para mí es importante y por eso
hay un personaje que nunca olvida
genera fibras y siento que como personas
físicas aprendió sobre eso
me visitas en exceso y tal vez ella no
existe tal vez es un país por una
persona no lo sabemos pero la clave es
simplemente ser consciente consciente de
lo que pasó y consciente de la hora
cuando yo zinc
porque crees que este filme no hubiera
sido viable en tailandia porque si hay
realidades comunes entre los países ya
sea estatal danés
si siento que tailandia estaba muy cerca
de casa de mis raíces
hay un cierto marco de pensamiento que
le pongo a mi país
buena piel afirmó fe pero cuando estoy
aquí me siento más libre
especialmente con el hermoso apoyo de
los miembros del equipo la productora
es como estar en un aula aprendes la
historia de la gente de aquí y cómo se
viste cómo se come
de hecho así que para mí a esta edad y
en este punto de mi carrera es laica el
herceptin es un regalo venir aquí y
abrazar esta idea de no saber desde
haití knowing
y decirme a mí mismo que está bien no
saber no necesitas buscar en internet
simplemente siente y eso para mí fue una
experiencia muy hermosa al hacer esta
película
cuál es la situación allí
en el sentido de la situación política y
la libertad para el arte
fue duro para los creadores es decir
para los cineastas los escritores
incluso para los youtubers o los
instagramers o
one
efectos se ven afectados por este
gobierno autoritario
el gobierno tiene una idea de lo que
debe ser una sociedad pacífica
así que son muy estrictos
contacte con to make you so met o tienen
una especie de táctica para que uno se
someta y tenga miedo
incluyen hacen todo tipo de cosas
incluyendo la infiltración en covent
oficios usan funcionarios del gobierno
en línea a mí es como un ejército en
línea
para crear un conflicto de información o
verdades
y para mí eso es realmente triste pero
no me sorprende ver noches prising
teniendo en cuenta el pasado
en este tipo de beca pero lo bueno es
que la gente ya despertó me refiero a
las generaciones más jóvenes
y que a su vez inspiraron a mi
generación es decir
estos jóvenes son muy valientes nosotros
una generación mayor estábamos tan
acostumbrados a ser silenciosos y
sumisos y ahora empezamos a hablar
también la wii status pictures o toque
derby así que juntos como en colombia
creo que empezamos a levantar nuestras
voces para hacer preguntas
memoria up y escribiste memoria pensando
en trabajar con tilda swinton y yang
bolívar que es como tilda que para crear
mejor debe haber un vínculo amistoso
para mí si en mi caso no creo que pueda
trabajar con
mi
[Música]
profesión ya sabes actores profesionales
y con la industria discos tommy
porque para mí se trata de colaborar y
descubrir juntos de qué va la película
así que es algo que lleva tiempo
dentro de la película como tilda no como
la actriz
sino más bien como una amiga
es un placer estar juntos para explorar
este país y explorar los sentimientos
internos porque ella también tiene su
propio dolor todo el mundo lo tiene y
como lo que analizamos en esta película
ahora en su desfile
como es trabajar con tilde cómo actúa
despacio es fácil desde el primer día
que vino
y aprendió español antes de su viaje y
cambió su apariencia
juntos intentamos que fuera jessica no
tildada por mí
data de datos
para mí la belleza del cine es el
proceso de creación
a veces no se trata de la horca cv la
final sino del camino que tomamos y de
abrazar los problemas y resolverlos
juntos
y hacer eso con dida y el resto fue
realmente muy divertido si es porque
ella está llena de alegría
pero no abajo y no sé si sea así en
otras producciones pero en esta
producción es casi como si ella hubiera
sido quien ancló el lugar el espíritu de
la película
y quien hizo que todo el mundo
disfrutará realmente trabajar y tuvimos
varias fiestas y bailes y buena comida
así que es realmente un regalo de aquí
sé que tus memorias hay un vínculo con
los hospitales por tus padres doctores
pero esta relación con latinoamérica
esas referencias surgieron en ti por
libros por películas también esta idea
de lo extraterrestre
[Música]
de mi infancia
porque antes de venir aquí creo que
muchos de nosotros en muchos lugares del
mundo tenemos una profunda curiosidad
por el amazonas
y por la civilización de esta región
whittingdale y yo crecí leyendo estos
libros de aventuras
escritos en tailandés por autores
tailandeses
que se inspiraron en esta selva
amazónica pero cambiaron el contexto a
la selva tailandesa y chanco vino
es fascinante
en mi mente estar fresh y para mí al
venir aquí quería un nuevo comienzo pero
al mismo tiempo sentirme joven volver a
la juventud y empezar de nuevo
[Música]
así que surgió esta idea sobre la
ciencia ficción sobre la aventura y
sobre la posibilidad de una civilización
diferente porque yo también soy un
visitante aquí así que existe ese
vínculo social
y refrendó además de eso también hay una
especie de referencia a esta vieja
ilustración del libro de ciencia ficción
de ray bradbury de isaac asimov toscano
esta especie del pasado futuro no es
realmente el futuro
crees que para acabar que has iniciado
una nueva etapa filmográfica con memoria
que ha apartado tu idea de auto
retirarte como has afirmado
aitex o picos creo que sí porque están
en otro espacio con algo que no conoces
realmente activa el cerebro
y te sientes joven de nuevo aquí en mi
memoria y con memoria me sentí bendecido
por contar con mucho apoyo y un equipo
realmente bueno en colombia ha vivido
inicial
como
he sentido como creo que todo se puede
[Música]
están colectivos con un solo mundo
no siento la frontera del idioma de nada
tenemos el mismo sufrimiento tenemos la
misma felicidad es humano entonces me
inspiró a explorar más ya sea aquí o en
otros países de américa latina o incluso
en amazonas
ap joe muchísimas gracias por esta
entrevista de ensueño ha sido un placer
misma depresión
hablando
murphy
la gente
[Música]